in this video we're going to talk about
solubility
which is just a way of describing how
well certain solutes
can dissolve in certain sol vents and
just as an example we could go to our
old friend
sodium chloride and think about why does
it dissolve well in
water
well to do that you just have to remind
yourself what water water's doing when
nothing is dissolved in it so when
nothing is dissolved in it that's an
oxygen attached to two hydrogens
this end we've talked about in other
videos partially negative because the
electrons like to spend more time around
the oxygen this is partially positive
partially positive and you have this
hydrogen bond forming where the
partially negative end of one water
molecule is attracted to the partially
positive end
of another water molecule those that's
what hydrogen bonds are all about we
have whole videos on that actually many
videos on that
the reason why sodium chloride dissolves
well
in water is because sodium chloride as
an ionic compound it can disassociate
into its constituent ions
into
a sodium cation and a chloride anion
and we've seen this before so that's a
chloride anion this right over here is
a sodium
cation the reason why this dissolves
well is that the negative charge is able
to be drawn to the positive end of the
water molecule so the hydrogen end and
the positive sodium cation is attracted
to the negative end of the water
molecules so what's really happening is
the attraction between the ions and the
water molecules are stronger than the
attraction between the ions themselves
and the attractions between the water
molecules themselves so the water
molecules don't just bunch up and say we
want nothing to do with you sodium and
chloride to say hey we're kind of
attracted to you too so why don't we mix
together we can look at things that have
less attractive forces maybe things
where the main force is just dispersion
forces if you think about a vat of
pentane here they have those weak forces
kind of attracting them to each other
and if you think about a vat of hexane
here there's kind of weak forces but if
you were to put some pentane let's call
this the solute here
and if you were to put it into a solvent
of hexane it will dissolve because they
are roughly as attracted to each other
as they are to themselves
now what do you think is going to happen
if i try to put say some hexane if i
view that as a solute and i were to put
it in water
well in that situation the water is
going to be far more attracted to itself
than it's going to be attracted to the
hexane let's say that this is
the water here you're going to have
these globs of the hydrocarbon form
because the water is more attracted to
itself it's not easy for the hydrocarbon
to dissolve now there are many organic
molecules that do dissolve well and
that's usually because they have some
part of the molecule that has some
polarity to it
one example is ethanol which has an oh
group but ethanol which has a chain of
two carbons when we talk about alcohol
in everyday language drinking alcohol
that is ethanol there's many other anals
many other alcohols but this is ethanol
here and if you were to take alcohol and
you were to mix it in water it does
dissolve well and that's because this
oxygen here it's more electronegative
than the things that it is bonded to and
so it still hogs electrons a little bit
and so you still have that partially
negative charge you still have that
polarity to the molecule and so that's
able to attract it to neighboring water
molecules which allows it to dissolve
but you can imagine if you had an
alcohol that had a much much longer
carbon chain say you had 10 carbons or
15 carbons then all of a sudden the
relative proportion of how polar it is
compared to how large of the molecule it
is it'll become it'll make it harder and
harder for it to dissolve in a polar
solvent like water
and so a mega takeaway here is that like
dissolves like